[Musique]
si j'avais un robot je ferai du cinéma
mais pour mieux comprendre pourquoi pas
revenir un petit peu en arrière j'ai 7
ans comme souvent je bricole tout seul
dans l'atelier de mon grand-père une
grande cape silencieuse les rêves 3 et
beaucoup de poussière un peu partout je
passe des heures à chercher dans les
caisses les tiroirs et avec ce que je
trouve je pers
je coupe le ponce assez maladroitement
j'imagine bien l'horreur dans les yeux
d'un menuisier qui me verrais utiliser
une lime ou un ciseau à bois
mais même si c'est pas vraiment fait
dans les règles de l'art j'arrive à mes
fins une canne à pêche un bouclier une
épée un pistolet ils ont tous l'air un
peu rafistolé j'aurai avec pendant des
années et puis une fois je passe
l'après-midi avec mon grand-père et on
bricole ensemble on bricole ensemble
mais c'est du bricolage
sérieux il m'apprend à construire un
marteau alors ensemble en perse en
coupon réponse à la fin d'après midi
c'est pas une épée que brandit fièrement
un beau marteau un bon marteau tout neuf
alors là tout change parce que je me
rends compte qu'on n'a pas construit
n'importe quoi c'est pas que j'ai enfin
appris à correctement utilisé une lime
ou un ciseau à bois et on a construit un
objet est aussi un outil un objet qui
sert à construire d'autres objets avec
mon nouveau marteau je peux construire
les autres nouveau marteau alors là tout
change parce que je me rends compte que
je deviens de plus en plus intéressés
par les outils en fait un outil c'est un
peu comme une baguette magique mais
qu'on peut changer les choses autour de
nous ça va des premiers silex jusqu'aux
dernières imprimantes 3d sont des outils
qui nous permettent de construire
d'autres outils par exemple avec ma main
je peux ramasser un caillou et pij peut
tailler un autre caillou pour le rendre
tranchant mecs cacher ce caillou je peux
couper une branche avec cette branche et
sky où j'ai une hache
avec cet âge peut couper un arbre avec
cette arme je peux construire un bateau
et avec ce bateau je navigue à l'autre
bout du monde
donc à chaque nouvel outil je peux aller
plus loin je peux construire plus grand
plus précis plus lourd c'est un peu une
course au progrès et qui renferme aussi
sa chute
le philosophe paul virilio
il dit que quand on a inventé le bateau
on a aussi inventé le naufrage alors je
me rends compte que quand j'ai construit
une belle h
je risque aussi de couper toute la forêt
avec en 2007 j'ai étudié la physique à
l'université
là je prenais vraiment comment mon
marteau fonctionne accélération énergie
cinétique mécanique des solides
je me rends compte qu'en fait ce qui
m'intéresse vraiment c'est de construire
des marteaux alors j'arrête l'université
j'ai commencé à étudier le design là je
passe mon temps à construire des outils
qui travaillent à ma place je passe mes
nuits à lire des manuels d'électronique
de programmation et puis petit à petit
mes outils deviennent des machines des
machines outils j'étudiais sont là le
design graphique donc je décide de ne
pas construire n'importe quelle machine
je construis des machines à écrire je
reçus des machines à dessiner machine à
imprimer
en fait ce qui m'intéresse c'est de
construire des machines qui n'existent
pas pas simplement pour faire des choses
différentes pour essayer de réfléchir en
dehors
la boîte à outils existantes du design
les possibilités qui nous sont offertes
par les objets et logiciels qui nous
entoure elles ont été précisément décidé
souvent on oublie que ça pourrait
fonctionner différemment
alors moi dans mon travail je décide ne
pas être limité par ses contraintes
techniques qui ne sont imposés 6 manque
une fonction un logiciel
je peux la programmer moi même si un
outil fonctionne
pas comme je souhaite je peux le
construire moi-même cette manière je
contrôle comment je travaille je me
libère des choix qui me sont imposés
dans mon travail ça devient une
constante de construire ses propres
outils
ça devient un peu une émancipation une
subversion ma première machine
elles servent à imprimé avec des
feuilles de papier carbone
j'aimais beaucoup la couleur du pigment
bleu déposé par ses feuilles soient
papier c'est pas normalement on peut
seulement tracé avec un stylo moi ce qui
m'intéressait c'était d'utiliser cette
technique d'impression mais avec des
images
c'était assez simple suffisait de poser
une feuille sur une planche
et puis un petit marteau n'est frappé le
papier là où je voulais un point de
couleur c'était très rudimentaire et ça
m'avait permis de comprendre tout mon
flux de production du début à la fin
j'avais programmé le logiciel qui
faisait tous marcher et j'avais
construit les moteurs qui faisait tout
avancer j'avais tout compris plus tard
pour mon diplôme je développe à une
autre machine
qui cette fois imprimé avec les stylos
feutres sur des gros rouleaux de papier
journal
là ça fonctionnait comme une sorte de
grand livre d'or les visiteurs d'une
exposition pouvait laisser des messages
sur un site internet
et puis la machine les écrivais
automatiquement ça crée une sorte de
discussions entre ma machine mon site
internet les visiteurs c'était un peu un
méli mélo entre digitale et physique
tout cela m'amène petit à petit a
développé une pratique artistique qui
s'intéresse pas seulement aux résultats
mais au processus de production
la manière dont produits les choses donc
je design le résultat mais surtout le
contact qui mène aux résultats et puis
il ya aussi une constante qui apparaît
dans mes travaux petit à petit c'est le
mouvement que ce soit un marteau un
stylo ou un feutre à toutes ces machines
en fait elles font bouger mes outils de
manière bien précise
donc je deviens une sorte de
chorégraphes qui fait danser mes
machines ça reviendra régulièrement dans
tous ses projets ce besoin constant de
positionner de faire bouger ou de faire
danser les machines mais outils et puis
il ya quelques années je tombe nez à nez
avec un robot industriel alors là c'est
vraiment le moment époustouflant c'est
vraiment une machine hyper inhabituel
incroyable
c'est énorme c'est massif se déplace
avec une dextérité ahurissante
mais avec toutes ces années passées à
bricoler et à apprendre comment mes
outils fonctionnent j'en deviens
vraiment fasciné donc je commence à
faire un peu de recherche
et puis je me rends compte que et un
marché de l'occasion en fait assez
fourni assez développé c'est une machine
relativement accessible et surtout c'est
une machine pas si compliqué que ça
en fait pour moi un robot c'est juste un
gros marteau
mais donc si un robot qui est conçu pour
fonctionner dans une usine
eh ben je m'en servais pour le détourner
et faire autre chose avec
à quoi ça pourrait bien ressembler un
robot qui passe pas ses journées à
construire des voitures robots qui passe
pas ses nuits à mettre des cartons sur
des palettes mais un robot qui devient
simplement un outil dans mon travail et
qui me permet pas de faire bouger mes
stylos mais marteau comme je veux alors
pour ça il ya peu de temps j'ai cofondé
un studio de robotique qu'on a défini
comme la robotique non industrielle la
robotique
or l' usine là on essaie de développer
des projets qui utilisent la robotique
mais dans des contextes un peu
inhabituel on imagine un monde où les
robots sont pas que là pour travailler
mais aussi là pour jouer et moi pour moi
ce mot il est important de jouer parce
que comme un enfant on joue pas pour
rien on joue pour développer son
intelligence joue pour développer son
imagination sa créativité
on joue pour apprendre à s'entraider à
collaborer alors pour moi jouer avec un
robot et à apprendre à un robot de jouer
c'est un peu essayé de chercher quelle
est sa place et son sens dans notre
culture ou dans notre société
mon premier robot dans son ancienne vie
il faisait du repassage toute la journée
travailler dans un centre de test et ils
simulaient l'utilisation de fer à
repasser toute la journée et maintenant
dans sa nouvelle vie eh bien il fait du
cinéma
parce que s'il ya une chose que les
robots savent très bien faire
et bien justement c'est de bouger très
précisément alors quand on leur donne
une caméra de vlad est placé exactement
comme on veut le faire des mouvements
impossible à faire autrement et surtout
il peut le faire encore et encore et
encore c'est le rêve d'un réalisateur
si j'avais un robot je ferai du cinéma
sinon j'ai été souvent invité dans des
dans des institutions pour développer
des cours autour cette question de la
robotique dans la création
alors je me suis demandé est-ce que je
pourrais apprendre à mon robot à écrire
j'ai développé un petit logiciel
que j'ai donné à des étudiants en
typographie et avec ça ils ont pu
dessiner des lettres ensuite le robot
elle est découpée dans la mousse et puis
on a pu expérimenter pour faire tes mots
en 3d si j'avais un robot je ferai de la
calligraphie avec d'autres étudiants
on s'est demandé qu'est ce qu'un robot
pourrait bien faire s'il devait pas
travailler toute la journée ils avaient
aussi le droit de s'amuser un peu
alors on s'est dit peut-être qu'il
aurait envie de s'amuser en faisant des
bulles
si j'avais un robot je lui apprendrai à
épater la galerie
et puis une autre fois on s'est demandé
qu'est ce qu'un robot pourrait bien
faire s'il fait seulement ce qui se fait
de mieux c'est à dire bouger
parfaitement
alors on lui a donné une lumière et il
bouge toute la journée ça devient un
cadran solaire
c'est un robot qui donne l'heure en fait
si j'avais un robot je pourrais même me
construire un soleil il ya deux ans
j'étais invité à la fondation luma à
arles pour proposer un projet de
recherche en design
alors j'en ai profité justement pour
proposer un projet qui mêle passé et
futur
c'est une approche contemporaine de
l'artisanat qui mêle le territoire et
les nouvelles technologies
c'est une recherche autour de la taille
de pierre alors on n'est pas encore en
train de construire des cathédrales et
on espère trouver des pistes qui nous
mène vers un futur où les objets sont
juste devenus un outil comme un autre
dans la continuité de tous mes autres
projets c'est une recherche multi
facettes mais qui s'intéresse toujours à
cette question du développement d'outils
qui nous apprennent nouvelle manière de
travailler
en fait pour moi jouer avec tous ces
robots c'est une manière d apprivoiser
se demander à quoi il pourrait bien
servir s'ils deviennent juste quelque
chose de banal
et même si certains projets ont l'air un
peu futile peut-être qu'ils nous
pointent vers un futur qui se profile un
futur où les robots font des choses un
peu plus inattendu et un peu plus
sensibles au fond qu'est ce que ça nous
raconte qu est ce que ça nous raconte un
robot qui peint un robot qui danse
ça nous donne le choix
ça nous donne le choix ça nous donne la
possibilité d'être un acteur de pas
seulement subir les technologies mais
aussi d'avoir le droit de les imaginer
pouvoir proposer des choses différentes
en fait connaître ces outils j'ai gagné
une sorte d'indépendance
quand j'avais 7 ans dans l'atelier de
mon grand père mais je savais pas trop
ce que je faisais avec tous ces outils
et maintenant j'ai fait beaucoup de
chemin depuis ce marteau mais souvent
avec ses robots je sais pas trop ce que
je fais non plus mais peut-être qu'en
fait c'est ça qui rend le jeu assez
intéressant que personne n'a vraiment
d'idée de ce qu'on va faire avec ses
robots mais qu'on cherche tous ensemble
qu'on expérimente qu'on essaie des
choses sérieuses des choses maladroite
mais qu'on essaie de chercher et de
trouver ce qui nous convient vraiment
pour nous alors vous si vous aviez un
robot vous feriez quoi merci
[Applaudissements]